i disagree i would say  because it does take two to tango  because here's the thing right  it is true that most men would have sex  with anything yeah  but they're the small percentage of men  who maybe have a lot of options wouldn't  they exercise  discipline especially if their time is  money right but even even if let's say  they wear a condom right what happened  to drake  how does it count it does count that  happens to really successful men all the  time what i mean is like that's not  that's completely unheard that's not  even one person that's what i'm saying  like even if a guy wears a condom a girl  can take it  it's true that's that's true that like  that's that's not his fault but i would  say if she got pregnant from that that's  that's not 99 her that's 100 her yeah  that's none of him yeah i'm saying if it  was